you'll get the giggles yeah then you
can't stop yeah
and I'm wondering you're on this yeah
you're on this big successful show berry
it's HBO time is money
yeah there's there's a lot of pressure
do you lose it on Berry as a
professional actor now all the time yeah
oh yeah they haven't conquered that no
no I haven't conquered that at all if
you watch me on Saturday live you know I
laughed pretty much all the time and
then and then yeah when I mean if you
watch the episode - this season the
Henry Winkler does this thing where he
does the the Brian Dennehy it's like
this bag thing and he and every time he
did it Henry you go like this and if you
watch the cameras behind me my eyes are
closed like this because I couldn't look
at him because I kept laughing and and
Anthony Kerrigan who plays NoHo Hank he
constantly makes me break that guy makes
me laugh so hard and there is a scene
last week's episode we were on top of a
roof and and he did this very funny
thing with this other guy named Troy
where Troy gets shot and he's on the
ground I've shot him and he's in pain
and then me and Hank are having this
argument and I go he goes I want you to
train my guys and I go I can't you guys
are great he goes no you know my guys
are in Troy is supposed to say well if
you're the king of mountain right okay
that's funny we wrote that yeah yeah me
and Alec we're like well geez work
mom it is alright bring my carriage
around what I must kill the mutton for
the day that I have yeah it's very age
of innocence but but no then and then
Anthony being a very good actor to throw
off Hank he said instead of saying my
guys he goes my guys suck so therefore
it Troy had to say wee wees up near the
king of suck and I saw Troy do the math
in his head it made me laugh so hard he
goes my gosh and I could tell that
Anthony was kind of doing it on purpose
to see if to give something to Troy's
like my guys suck something kind of like
a little smile on his say he's in Troy
going well if we stop joking aside
[Laughter]
before what how long it you oh I wanted
that the whole time and it was like a
hundred degrees on top of this roof and
everybody was like bill get it together
we gotta go we're all burning up here
and I go I yeah just the amount is so
funny